last time that you plugged a an  appearance that you were gonna do at  Carnegie Hall now this in America that's  the highest thing you can achieve your  parents were they impressed and you told  them because they're not from here no I  mean that was a it's been a crazy  journey you know touring all over the  u.s. starting over again in another  language another language yeah  and when I knew I was gonna do Carnegie  Hall I was so impressed and honored and  nervous I called up my mother and  friends I said I'm gonna do Carnegie Oh  but she didn't know what Carnegie was  yeah for her it was like just another  room you know just in one more theater  and then she flew in and she she walked  into the theater the night of the show  and she stopped right in front of a  picture of Frank Sinatra and I thought  she was going to get emotional and tell  me something finally nice she said she  turned and said you better be good yeah  proud and so happy really  you